[Music]
from their Mountain Homes to the streets
of the small town of uripahaya bindi
Andes
[Applause]
hundreds of farmers joined in
they marched demanding the rights to
promises former president Pedro Castillo
made during his campaign
says she will not give up on the
expectations she had when she voted for
him 18 months ago the laws are made to
favor the rich we don't have a voice or
a vote we want a constituent assembly to
close Congress and we want president
Dina bulata to resign she does not
represent us
many protesters here say Castillo's
removal from office and arrest make him
a political prisoner
Castillo ordered the dissolution of
Congress and the arrest of the
prosecutor investigating him on
corruption allegations now he faces
charges of rebellion and up to 20 years
in prison
[Music]
with vote
of hearsay he didn't fulfill any of the
promises he made they say it's the
lawmaker's responsibility because they
did not allow Castillo to work
without Castillo these Farmers see their
expectations for better living
conditions slipping away they blame the
new president Dina boluarte
promised agrarian reforms and we voted
for him but now bolarte has betrayed us
she was our sister but now we want her
out
for a month Peru has witnessed protests
death and destruction the country is in
a state of emergency Farmers here are
continuously on strike taking turns to
block the main Highway
we are so tired all of us the elderly
children but we're all taking part in
the fight it's the only way if they
don't listen to us we will continue with
our fight
one month on Pedro Castillo is a symbol
fading away but the people of uripa say
his promises are now a force for renewed
hope and the only way for change they
say is to continue fighting Mariana
Sanchez
[Applause]